oh I'm Goldie Hawn and we are doing a
wired complete interview right my name's
Schumer and I'm doing that with her
where's my toadstool what Amy Schumer
what is Amy Schumer long what is the
theme song for inside Amy Schumer
I was written by quick slow yeah I love
that I migrate I do one is Amy Schumer
famous for I'm trying not to say
something dirty but it is anal so margin
okay what does Amy Schumer look like
Google Gisele what is Amy Schumer's
favorite app phone or like potato skins
what is it what is Amy Schumer's
ethnicity it's not interesting you know
I think we're both like Austrians yeah
that's right so we have had the Austrian
you know sort of the Ashkenazi kind of
thing and you know I had a couple horse
thieves and few people that were of note
and I still think it's a gypsy mess yeah
I swear I do
oh we're just without yes well we'll
meet all your gypsy needs okay what does
Amy Schumer eat everything
okay okay what is going on doing now
doing now I'm with Amy Oh what else am i
doing I just finished building a house
secondly I'm working with my foundation
which I've got almost two million
children now across the globe doing this
program mind up mind up thank you and
that's kind of what I'm doing what is
Goldie Hawn painting before how dare you
google that it's just a very verbal who
is Colby who are these people limits
what color is Goldie and homecare you're
looking at I know it's crazy I know it's
hard to believe but that my air is
not colored why most one worth a listen
to it we we I mean it just came I'm like
it's just way to join em accessory thank
you up what program is going on I'm a
perfume addict I love your perfume but
why do people know what you all I don't
know I'm actually weirded out I know it
is kind of where now I'm scared
there is kind of a thing but I will say
there is a Jasmine perfume that I wear
did you get into that yeah yeah but I
feel to be wearing it but I do like
sniff it what I did do a lot of great
meeting nobody know anyway i from here
is my passion which is Goldie Hawn eat
green juice I'm eating vegetables
I have ups I do coconut juice I you mad
bad I like oysters
yeah and I like go wine what is Goulding
on eating I guess in the movie death
becomes her I'm trying to remember I
don't have a mirror like eat it well I
don't have a full-on aunt chicken this
is scary yeah I know because you know
that gave me anything
oh this is Amy Schumer dating amber rose
that is no no you would love her you
know I was a stripper actually an Amber
Rose I mean it sounds like I mean are we
all strippers you are and that's true
I'm strapped but you know why they asked
us because my guys at the MTV was here
first bit we kissed and I like when all
we're even doing a bit oh right like the
sexiest oh okay got the raw night they
got the ride yeah that scene better play
you have fun and then all of a sudden
seems like a thing is Amy Schumer from
Long Island solid represent yeah yeah
exactly
I like do you rich long that's the only
thing it's lean - yeah I got a dick is
her name right is Amy Schumer
left-handed that's like what all the
guys I've ever like jerked off ass
because I was so bad oh really you're
like are you left-handed
right away no so quick I'm sorry about
that okay is Amy Schumer but you behind
bars
oh that's really funny I know I've read
a couple times but I've been arrested
for getting in in fistfights over in
cities where I'm not in I'm not lying
borrower she's not but thank you
oh this is me this is you okay how
Goldie Hawn how is holding on people
will like Chicago is Goldie funny
Goldie's good good yeah I'm really good
moving to new house kids are great life
is good I'm sitting next to my other
daughter this is all working out so so
far how was goldie hawn discovered I was
dancing and that a man came up to me and
asked me if I had agent and I said no
and he said here's my card
and I said thank you very much and I put
it into my brach as I was getting ready
to go back to rehearsal and I just
thought he wanted a date and I never
called him again until they called me at
my apartment afterwards and said Isis
Goldie Hawn well we're waiting for you
here at William Morris Agency and I went
you are and I got in my car which did
not have a floor in it okay you know I
think this our own yeah kind of like
that it was an old jalopy and that's how
good that sounds started oh my god never
know when you today knows what's going
to happen so may God biess is different
in Grace's it's how people are at just
dancing at least it wasn't on a table
yeah okay that's true how bullion doing
again like you feel just donít know
there's an eye on containing a sweetness
and a concern I just want to share with
you I'm fine who's worried about you and
I'm good I know and I'm still riding the
miles babe and Raymond look at your eye
and you know as a very sweet thing so I
I appreciate it okay let me ask how I
lose
okay how to get goldie hawn how to get
holding on hair a little bit threatening
a little bit scary because getting my
ears a different thing of like
replicating my yeah your hair how i was
great it does and well first of all when
I was born I was born bald mmm
now I came out blonde really blonde the
color is that was the things how do you
get it I guess you have to come from
Laura home and run on just come yeah it
fell true see I got it's easy I came out
and I would I'm blonde tall as holding
on Goldie Hawn is five foot six inches
tall perfect in every way I wish I was
five seven yeah but you can I lie about
it yeah okay there we go
oh can blonde evolve I think that
blondes have nothing to do with
evolution there were no blonde monkeys
no I there well you know listen I've
seen a monkey or two and I've seen some
hair and I look at that and there are
streaks and they do you know there's
streaks of one can blonde
make a good wife I don't know how to
answer that yeah no I mean I I've never
been a good way okay can blonde be
Jewish yeah ten blonde make a ginger
baby
absolutely why not like the hair color
not you're not picturing like a little
gingerbread man right it could be but I
wasn't thinking gingerbread know
everything like a redhead well first of
all blondes actually have a lot of red
in their hair true yeah yeah so my
family had a lot of red hair mm-hmm and
I call it kind of that ginger look yeah
I say yeah yeah we can make a ginger
baby for you I know of one right up okay
come on I hope on the try oh my gosh
Ellen here
Blum be email we're skipping that Kim
blonds count let me tell you look at you
three ways okay good that we can you
know our blonde dying out and what an
interesting idea those work that laws
are dying out our blog and raising evil
no I learned that I mean it's not
surprising people just want to kind of
check in on you
I was called II doing no no but their
level of curiosity I find interesting
one thing is that we learned nothing but
we have fun oh so fun this isn't fun
game it kind of well is it a game I
don't know but anyway it was fun
I know yeah